[Music]
the world is on edge as omicron the new
variant of kovid 19
spreads around the world
britain germany and italy announced
their first omicron cases
countries are scrambling to contain
transmission researchers say it could be
the most infectious form of the virus so
far what does the new strain mean for
the global fight against covid19
our experts answer your questions
[Music]
why has it been designated as a variant
of concern
iocron has been designated as a variant
of concern because of the large number
of mutations to its spike protein it has
more mutations than any other variant
that has been observed so far by genomic
surveillance and a large number of those
mutations are on sites of the spike
protein which are known as the binding
domain which is the bit of the spike
that binds to your cells and they're
also the bit of the spike on which
antibodies the
the parts of your immune system which
protect you from infection
bind in order to prevent that from
happening so lots of mutations on sites
where antibodies are being created is of
concern between the mutations discovered
on the virus itself and this
epidemiological
data
there is there are reasons to believe
that
amicron may indeed be a lot more
contagious than delta which is the
current variant
dominant around the world
is omicron more dangerous than the delta
variant
we don't know yet whether omicron causes
more severe disease than delta or other
variants
it's still too early to tell
however preliminary evidence suggests
that this may not be the case and that
really hasn't been the case with
previous variants they usually are a lot
more contagious but they're not deadlier
but what we can be fairly confident
about is that at least for the component
of your immune system that the
antibodies
run that that one of the what's known as
the humoral immune system
the variant is going to erode the
immunity conferred by vaccines to
almost certainly a greater extent than
any of the other variants that have
emerged so far that's thanks to all of
those mutations on the receptor binding
domain of the spike protein
but what we don't know is how far it's
going to spread and how sick it's going
to make people when it does or if it
does and all of that data is coming in
over the next two weeks
will new vaccines be needed
the truth is that we don't know yet
whether we are going to need new
vaccines for omicron that depends on
both how
widely it spreads around the world and
the degree to which it erodes immunity
either that built up through infection
or vaccination if the answer to both of
those is a lot
then we may need to update them but the
good news is that that's a quick process
it takes only a couple of weeks to do
the technical bits and then a few more
weeks for the safety checks and to spin
up mass production
what are governments doing to contain
the spread of omicron
many many countries have banned travel
from south africa or have placed heavy
restrictions such as quarantines at
hotels for people arriving from there
of course these measures will only delay
the spread of the virus if indeed it
turns out
to be
a lot more contagious than delta in
which case it will eventually overtake
delta as the dominant variant worldwide
but these measures can temporarily
slow down
any outbreaks that omicron may cause
as well as implementing a travel ban the
british government has
reintroduced rules about mask wearing in
public spaces and on public transport
and has also reintroduced guidance
around social distancing
this is a sensible precaution given that
omicron is almost certainly already
seated in the community
is this new variant a setback in the
fight against kobit 19
but even if omicron comes to dominate as
the variant worldwide we are not back at
square one we do have vaccines which are
probably going to work very well against
severe infection
severe disease and death
and we also have
lots of drugs now
which
may work
against amicron
there's also some optimism to be had by
gaining a slightly more complete
understanding of the immune system
almost all of the discourse around
immunity focuses on just one segment of
the immune system which is antibodies
but there's a whole other deeper section
of the immune system known as the t cell
or cellular immune system and because of
the way that works which is
very very complicated and much more
unique on a per person basis it's much
much harder for variants to escape it
and there is no reason that has emerged
to date
that we would expect omicron to escape
that as well and immunologists that i
have spoken to are hopeful that even if
omicron does erode immunity at the
antibody level of the system
that cellular immunity that deeper
immunity will still be there for us even
as it spreads around the world
thank you for watching if you'd like to
learn more about omicron please click on
the link and don't forget to subscribe